and by the way dr fauci is insistent
after all the power grabs he's had after
all the demands he's made of you
wear the mask take the vex lock yourself
up
don't have christmas don't have
thanksgiving don't
shut up sheep all the demands he's made
he now wants
your three-year-old child to wear those
filthy cloth masks
now we're a year and a half past 15 days
to slow this bread
he wants your little kid to wear those
masks he said there is no doubt
that that's the right thing to do the
children who are not
able to get vaccinated because of their
age
should follow their parents should
follow with them the guidelines
of the cdc that unvaccinated children
of a certain age greater than two years
old should be wearing masks
no doubt about that that's the way to
protect them from getting infected
because if they do
they can then spread the infection to
someone else
so the cdc guidelines for unvaccinated
people including children
are not changed at all
you see the three-year-olds who even dr
fauci i think is tacitly admitting here
face an infinitesimally small risk of
any serious complication from kovid
the three-year-olds you see if they
don't wear the masks which
dr fatchi told us at the very beginning
of the pandemic are not effective
at preventing the spread of a virus and
then he contradicted himself later on
and there have been studies that have
raised a lot of questions about this
which we've read on this show even
though big tech doesn't want us to
what dr fauci is saying is even if the
three-year-olds don't face a great risk
from covet
they can spread it if they don't wear
the mask now you might be saying michael
all the other people are vaccinated so
if you're at a demographic
that is at r at very high risk of covid
presumably you are vaccinated at this
point the vaccines have been out for a
very long time if you're not vaccinated
there's a very specific reason why it's
very
intentional why you would not be so
if the vaccines work then the
three-year-old doesn't need to wear the
mask
but the vaccines i guess don't work at
preventing the spread
so therefore the three-year-olds need to
wear the mask but no the vaccines do
work
which is why you have to get it which is
why anyone 12 and up needs to get and
hopefully
children younger than that according to
the public health administration it's
it's whim it's caprice it's changing
every day much like political
correctness actually
the public health regime
which is just sort of the most
noticeable aspect of the broader
progressive technocratic regime is less
about the
rules themselves whatever the rules are
changing all the time
it's less about that and it's more about
the imposition of the rules the very
fact
that the dr fauci's of our technocratic
elite can just
get you to do whatever they want you to
do and they can say
don't go to church but you can go to a
casino and you can go to a liquor store
but you can't go to thanksgiving and
they can just
they can just make it up and you have to
follow it that's a big divide and i
think people across the political aisle
across the partisan lines are sick of
that sort of thing
yo hey you stop right there before you
click don't click
you got to ring the bell you got to
subscribe then you will hopefully get
the notifications though sometimes big
tech doesn't want
our followers to get the notifications
you can watch this whole episode it's
called save us floridaman
uh you can also get it on apple podcast
spotify google play stitcher myspace
xanga livejournal aol instant messenger
you can also order my book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
thank you to everyone who made it a
number one
national bestseller we really appreciate
that we really appreciate the new york
times too for snubbing us and
uh continuing to sell a lot of books for
us we really really appreciate that
thank you to all of you who have read
leave a comment we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you